ladies and gentlemen you may not be
aware Donald Trump is facing uh
eligibility questions for the 2024
presidential race in Colorado and in
Minnesota and in Michigan and probably a
bunch of other states but we've got
updates on the Minnesota hearing the AP
says Minnesota justices appear skeptical
that states should decide Trump's
ibility for the ballot I watched some of
this live and I got to say this these
hearings what we are watching right now
with the question of Donald Trump's
eligibility is an attempt by democrats
to run a stake through the heart of the
United States and the arguments made in
Minnesota really spell this out I'll
give it to you very simply I believe it
was Trump's lawyers who was arguing this
who was arguing this states do not have
the Constitutional authority to
determine eligibility they state
legislatures are given wide uh um a wide
capability or or wide um what's
responsibility and governance over
elections in their states but not
eligibility which is a federal question
meaning if someone's eligibility is
challenged it must be in a federal court
Donald Trump was questioned over this in
his impeachment hearings and was found
not to have engaged in Insurrection
therefore the question is done they're
now taking it to the states to argue he
did the argument was was was actually
really simple if someone's 27 years old
there's no question of fact you're not
eligible to run nobody has an issue with
it Insurrection is different
Insurrection has to be determined but
the Constitution at the federal level
determines the eligibility for a federal
elected official states don't get decide
who is eligible or not if it becomes
that de if Democrats succeed in even a
single state set a precedent then the
precedent will be there will never be a
us election again now hold on we'll have
North Korea style elections where you'll
have one person on the ballot why
elections will become instead of hey
let's go get as many votes as possible
it's time to go vote that's what we do
now but don't get me like don't get me
wrong I know it's all ballot harvesting
now it's it's it's months of work
knocking on doors and the goal is get a
bigger number than the opponent by any
means necessary if this goes through and
Democrats succeed future elections will
be like this um okay uh uh sir it is one
year before the en which means it's
eligibility season we better get those
arguments ready for court to determine
whether or not you're eligible to be in
this state a president will then have to
win eligibility hearings in all 50
states and if they don't their name will
not appear on the ballot a dummy
candidate will and it will be like a
North Korean election in every state you
will then get every blue State saying
Joe Biden and you know uh Bobby Bobby
doe the Republican no one's ever heard
of him doesn't matter it's Joe Biden
versus Bobby and everyone's like who's
that well that means that there's not
going to be a popular vote for Trump
then the red States will do the same
thing well Joe Biden's not eligible
actually it's probably the Republicans
will do nothing and it'll only be the
blue states that are cutting off all the
Republicans but theoretically then red
States say nope we had we had
eligibility hearings a year ago and we
found Joe Biden to be ineligible for
these reasons therefore the Bel will
only be Donald Trump and the Democrat
will be RFK Jr and then Trump wins
easily and then you're going to get red
leaning swing states and leing swing
States and that's going to be the battle
where instead of an
election appointed
officials hired corporate lawyers will
argue to judges who the president should
be I don't know about you but it sounds
like a great segue to National divorce
myself you know ain't happen I'm a fan I
uh this ain't happening no this isn't
going to happen and if and if this if
this goes through no no this could
happen I don't think I don't think these
judges are hyper-partisan I know they
are look at the the judge in Colorado is
a donor to a pack specifically to remove
Republican who supported Trump on
January 6 our our whole entire justice
system has become hyper partis I'm not
under what's going to stop this Colorado
judge who already donated money to stop
Republicans over January 6 what's going
to stop that judge from being like I
don't care what you said Trump your
name's stop the Supreme Court I think
it'll it'll get argued to the Supreme
Court and and and how many years will
that take before The Supreme takes
Supreme Court takes it up I don't know
it could be fast it could be probably
would be pretty fast concerning uh
elections like that and then happens if
in
Colorado my fear is November uh let's
say October
2024 a state like Michigan will just
take Trump off the ballot and say sue us
then the Trump campaign will sue and
win and then by December 15th they'll
get injunctive relief oh what's that Joe
Biden already won sorry we can't undo
the election it was one state any one
one State's moot true that one state
would have would have changed the
election but then they then they argue
yes but your honor here's four states
where it happened too well you got to
take it up with those judges in those
states that has nothing to do with us
it's it's only seven electoral votes
here so you don't win then he's going to
go to that state ah it's only 13 here so
you don't win yeah I just I don't see it
I don't see it getting that far I really
don't I don't I honestly don't think it
can get that far I got to be honest man
you think it's not going to get that far
considering everything we've seen I'm
pretty blackpilled on a lot of this
stuff and I'm say I I I would be very
surprised if that if that got that far
and i' be very and I'd be very surprised
if it did go through that it wouldn't
was January surprising too yes of course
it should be surprising every viscerally
surprising I cannot believe that someone
would be surprised by what is literally
happening right now when you have
Colorado Minnesota and Michigan all
happening at the same time where they're
all arguing Trump should not be on the
ballot and a judge literally donated to
a pack to get Republicans removed from
Congress for supporting Trump I mean we
are we are one centimeter from okay when
you have judge donates money to Target
Trump supporters specifically over
January 6 then you have presiding over
whether Trump is eligible for January 6
it is a slight nudge to Trump ruling
Trump is not eligible there's also
there's a huge difference when we talk
about January 6 there's like a huge
difference between the federal courts
and and the state courts too um federal
courts always throw the book entirely at
everybody they have coming in hoping
they'll take a plea deal and like 80
something perc of the people go through
federal court take a ple plea deal
because the the consequences of not
taking one are so high astronomically
high that you can end up in prison for
two and a half life sentences for
building an e-commerce site like Ross
right and so like there's there is a a
distinction there for sure and I don't I
just I just don't see a state court
going that far I don't think I don't
think they can I don't think they I
don't I think at some point someone's
going to say judge you absolutely cannot
do this yeah that's what I think happen
right now so when that's what's happen
so when the judges in Pennsylvania ruled
that their own Constitution did not bar
them from passing Universal mail and
voting I don't understand how you go
from point A to point B on that one in
in Pennsylvania a lower Court rule ruled
that Universal mail and voting violated
the constitution of Pennsylvania Texas
filed their lawsuit the Supreme Court
refused to hear it so there wasn't even
a hearing over what was clearly a
violation of state constitution and the
and the justices of Pennsylvania said we
think absentee ballots and mailon votes
are a different thing so we're going to
allow Universal mail and voting despite
the fact the Constitution clearly says
you can't the upside is we've got a year
to talk about how insane this crap is
yeah that's true we need elections yeah
we have well even if they're getting
twisted behind the scenes 5149 we still
need them look at
Arizona what's what what what happens
with K Lake yeah how many several
several hundred machines did not read
bouts because the bouts were printed on
the wrong paper the wrong size printing
on the wrong size paper and but now
we're getting into like this Shadow vote
this like this Shadow voting stuff right
no no no we're no we're not we I'll keep
it real simple for you in Arizona it is
a fact no one disputes the voting
machines were not accepting in certain
areas because the wrong siiz image was
printed on the wrong siiz paper that
right there to any honest and reasonable
person is stop stop the election stop
stop stop we got to start over yeah we
don't have to rush elections these
exactly these ballots are wrong people
are complaining if we're going to have a
free and fair election we got to have un
like it's got to be Universal and
uniform the ballots instead they said
don't no don't care get out carry Lake
but we also got to remember that this
this uh election fraud thing has been
going on for a long long time it's
deeply entrenched right like it's been
deeply entrenched in our government for
many many many years but this is this is
my point this is new and this is going
to be visceral for a lot of people a lot
of people if we know for a fact that I
think it was several hundred locations
in Arizona the bouts were not properly
re being read and they and they argue no
no no we we counted all of them trust us
I'm like no that's not how elections
work this the the courts I mean k lake
is winning very narrowly in a few areas
and it's advancing now she's running for
Senate so we'll see if there ever an
answer but I mean they basically just
said everyone knows the election was
broken but we don't care and no one will
do anything about it this is the same
component they're just going and saying
we're going to win through law fair and
not an actual election and I'm not
putting it past them I don't want
anybody to think that I'm like
downplaying this at all I just if we do
nothing they'll if we do nothing it's
definitely what's going to Happ I do
want to stress I'm not saying it is
absolute that they're going to rule
against Trump I don't know but they're
trying and I would not be surprised at
all if they succeed considering I'll
just keep it very simple the judge in
the Colorado case donated money
specifically to remove Republicans who
supported Trump over January 6th and is
now presiding over the trial to
determine whether or not Trump is
ineligible to be president because of
his actions on January 6 I think we know
the biases of this judge I think he
needs to be removed for conflict of
interest well she was asked to accuse
herself and she said oh I don't remember
making that donation I don't care it
doesn't matter that's the thing I mean
it was up to her and there's no
oversight she said no no it's not a
conflict of interest I bet there's a
lawsuit hanging in there somewhere for
conflict of interest for they they
appeal but my my friends my fear is
first I'll say and I got to stress you
have to go vote you need a Title Wave of
votes you need everyone your grandmother
your kids you know who liian legally
allowed to vote I don't care who they
vote for just go vote go vote I don't
want anyone to be dissuaded from voting
because of these issues but I want to
make sure you understand the importance
of the law fair going forward that it be
two months 3 months four months before
the election one of these hearings hits
a state like Georgia the lower court
agrees and then orders the Secretary of
State to print boutots without Donald
Trump's name on it Trump files an appeal
the appeal goes to a higher Court who
reverses the decision secretary of state
says okay well now we got a bunch of
bels one way and the other then the the
state appeals or the or the Democrats
appeal and it goes to a higher court
that then says no no no Trump's
ineligible then Trump appeals and it
goes to the Supreme Court who says you
can't take Trump off off the Bel he is
eligible and it's a year after the oh so
maybe it's good that this is happening
now so we can get up to the Supreme
Court and they can shut it down it's I
mean if that goes through it's going to
the Supreme Court there's no doubt about
it zero in New York during Co but when
is the question the uh uh Cuomo the
governor shuts down churches he gets
sued saying the first amendment
guarantees our right to assemble you
can't shut down churches the the courts
agree and say you you can't shut them
down they reopen and he goes okay I'll
make a new executive order slightly
different sue me again
that's the problem even if it happens
now what what's what's happening now
especially with like people like Sydney
pow and Jenna Ellis apologizing and
saying yep we did it we did it you're
now going to have in these hearings
especially in Colorado they're going to
say look here's Trump staff saying they
were instructed to present
misinformation and disinformation for
the purpose of of subverting the
election with fake electors blah blah
blah okay well there's your evidence
then one Court says yes and then they
use it everywhere else it'll have to go
to the Supreme Court but the issue then
becomes
what's the Supreme Court is the Supreme
Court ruling going to be broad or narrow
right will the Supreme Court say in the
instance of Trump's eligibility as it
pertains to anything related to January
6 it is not in dispute Trump did not
engage an Insurrection and is eligible
okay or what they could do is issue a
narrow ruling where they say as to the
question raised specifically by this one
group this one time in Colorado we say
that they are wrong and Trump is
eligible and then what happens another
organization says okay well they didn't
answer the question of January 6 so
pursuing again and then it just keeps
happening until the Supreme Court issues
a broad ruling but I got to tell you I
think it's also a strong possibility the
Supreme Court says nah we're not going
to get involved in this one because
states can run their elections as they
see fit in Texas V Pennsylvania 2020
Texas said Pennsylvania violated their
constitu violated the Federal
Constitution by altering the rules of an
election without the approval of the
state legislature and therefore we are
negatively impacted if we are going to
participate in an election everyone has
to have these elections done fairly
Texas is basically saying if our
elections are fair and theirs are not
then the system is broken and the votes
are not legit for I think it was
something like 48 states get involved in
this lawsuit and the Supreme Court said
go f yourselves so the question's never
been answered and now you've got chaos
in in our election system because of
pathetic cowards in the Supreme Court
why didn't I why did they not take that
up did they say Thomas and Alita were
pissed they issu uh Thomas wrote this
like scathing opinion where he's like we
must take up questions in original
jurisdiction the states need to no they
need these questions answered and by
rejecting this we're leaving this
question in limbo and now all the states
are in a freefor all as to what is or is
not constitutional Alo agreed he wrote
his opinion and the rest were like no
we're not getting involved the real
reason was the Supreme Court cowards are
scared that this country is on the brink
you're talking about National divorce of
course yeah you you've got the Boston
Globe story where the Democrats were
proposing West West West uh uh West the
West Coast seceding from the union in
the event of a Donald Trump Victory and
so you likely have people like Kavanagh
being like well if I rule on this I mean
it could it could affect history right I
don't want to be involved in that I
don't I don't quit quit right now resign
all of you resign if you're unwilling to
take up a no they could have taken the
court case and said no you're wrong
Texas the ruling stands Biden's
president they just are cowards and if
you're on the Su Court that's kind of
your job to affect history I mean that
is why we put you there SC yeah but when
far-left extremists show up to your
house and threaten to kill you and the
and the police the judges are like we're
going to let it happen yeah I have
tremendous I have tremendous Sympathy
for the fear on the other hand if the
fear uh is now too great for you to
complete your job you should step down
if not otherwise you have an obligation
to continue to push forward that's why
these issues are important you have a
fiduciary duty I mean this is you have a
duty to the people to rule on these
matters that make it to the Supreme
Court there's no doubt about it and
because they didn't rule on it the
question remains open and will be an
issue again in 2024 and it's going to be
it's going to be apocalyptic law
now there's going to be like 3,000
lawsuits everybody who watched 2020
they're gearing up for law fair right
now and the Democrats are already in it
Republicans are are not going to be as
strong as Democrats on it but they're
gearing up as well it's going to be tens
of thousands of lawsuits what's what's
the fix for that public opinion shift in
public
opinion our culture public it's terrible
it's absolutely terrible it's cultural
fragmentation to where these judges not
these ones in Minnesota they appear
skeptical we'll see what happens
uh and and Minnesota being you know it's
it's not like the furthest of left
States it's you know little it's a
Midwestern so but uh with with Colorado
with California the culture is so
divided let me just put this way the
left is a cult they are uh either
malicious or or or um the banality of
evil and they go along with whatever
gains them power so I didn't I didn't
mean to interrupt but what do you think
is the solution building culture that's
exactly why we're doing it now granted I
see these problems I think in the
meantime we need need legal uh uh we
need law you know return legal fire uh
file lawsuits challenge these things and
everyone needs to vote in a massive
Title Wave but the real solution is
always going to be that politics is
Downstream from culture so what do we
need a cast brew coffee shop in every
shopping center I think but this is the
truth I'll tell you why because right
now everybody older you've got younger
people getting their information from
Tik Tock older people getting their
their news from mainstream media and
you're getting propaganda across the
board no one no one is getting an honest
shot you even on on on YouTube you get
you get partisan propaganda stuff but at
least as it pertains to the quote
unquote Freedom faction I like to say we
all try to be honest about what's going
on and then let people form their own
opinions and and and and we have a have
a real free and fair election the reason
why we want to do Cas Brew Coffee lady
walks into the coffee shop to buy her
coffee and you've got a TV playing on
the wall and guess what Josh Smith is on
doing an interview now they're hearing
another voice now they're getting a a a
wide range of opinions and Views not
just one
hyperarch more brick and morar locations
but we need to create spaces in the
physical world where people can meet
congregate and hang out used to be
Church it'd be great if it was we're
going to do this cash Brew Coffee we're
do Saturday morning cartoons invite
families to come and hang out their kids
and let people start rebuilding their
communities again you said Josh Smith
interview so I'm listening now you know
yeah I think we need to to put this show
on rumble or and I think the YouTube
admins should start shoving this show to
the front of the network but the
opposite of that good Lu buddy good luck
well yes that is good luck you should do
it because people need to know about
this stuff this needs to become
invigoratingly entertaining YouTube
doesn't want you to know about this
stuff YouTube not a guy youwork the
Google Executives cried when Donald
Trump won or I should say the Google
Executives held a meeting where staff
cried and they said we will never let
this happen again and we had uh Dr
Robert Epstein on the culture War
explaining it it's really really crazy
how he explains it's not complicated how
they how they can rig elections people
seem to think they hear the story about
Cambridge analytica right right oh they
were they were stealing data from
Facebook they weren't supposed to have
and using that to Target people and
figure out who they were voting for no
it's much simpler than that on Election
Day Mark Zuckerberg sitting there with
his paddle ball went oh can you send out
a notification to all Democrats to go
vote and top Republicans to go watch
Friends yeah but what's happening right
now the people the admins and the
executives are fuing terrified right now
dude he said in his data set of tens of
thousands of people he found 100% of
Democrats were given a notification to
go vote and only 59% of Republicans got
the same you don't need to trick or
convince anybody you just need to remind
one side and not the other there was
that study that uh I don't remember what
University students did sorry but it was
uh analyzing Gmail and Gmail would show
uh emails from democratic campaigns but
it would hide or mark spam uh Republican
campaigns I mean this is something that
and here's the best part when I think it
was Ted Cruz sent a letter to Google
over this he said in their data set they
saw instantly the the manipulation
turned off mean that that indicates
Google is intentionally doing it but
what's happening right now people are
terrified Biden screwed this country
hard people know that people are
freaking out that we're going to get
slaughtered because of the this
show of a leadership that we have and
they're willing to open and listen so we
are The Voice
and we need to inspire people and and
get people excite people to put this
on the front page make people hear
it it's super important we cannot let go
of our elections you know that we need
you this is where this is a team man
people who are watching MSNBC CNN and
Fox News aren't hearing this they they
they're I I don't even I don't even see
anybody tweeting about the Minnesota
case no like Colorado is getting a
little bit of AirPlay especially because
they showed a clip of this show so we
were like Hey look it's us I saw saw
cash Patel
seems like it's picking up I mean I was
just reading about like Ken Buck
testimony today uh it's getting underway
whereas I mean this true for a lot of
cases when it's the early stages of like
well judge is hearing this whatever
there's sort of less for the journalist
to report on but then when you're able
to say oh Donald Trump Jr and Eric Trump
are reporting today these things might
pick up it is a reason to me it seems
obvious that these these cases are all
hitting at the same time so it's hard to
keep track of them you don't know which
case is presenting what information
because they're arguing very similar
things and different jurisdictions uh
it's intentionally to confuse anyone who
might be trying to follow it so they
again you can retain control of the
narrative that gets out there well now
they have 24/7 World War III coverage to
watch too to keep them completely in the
dark on everything else would you rather
fight one horse-sized duck or a 100
duck-sized horses jeez you know the meme
yeah I know it's silly but here there
actually is a really simple answer a
horse-sized duck you know why you can
run from it yeah so the reason I bring
that up is Donald Trump is currently
fighting 100 duck-sized horses
and they're surrounding him in every
direction that is amazing sorry it and
it's important too because what's
happening right now is a single Democrat
voter in each state files a lawsuit with
only a couple thousand dollars and it
forces Trump's team to expand Nationwide
to every state and set up a legal
operation it's asymmetrical Warfare it
also means that you know and this is not
to be cruel to any of the lawyers
working on these cases but theoretically
the best lawyers that Trump can get
can't be in every single state the time
so Trump as a single individual in a
single campaign will need to hire
probably 300 lawyers let's be real maybe
that's not even enough okay if you're
talking about election eligibility you
you're not going to have one lawyer do
it you're going to hire a lawyer and
he's going to have a team of like five
or six he's going to need that in every
single state the Democrats no no no no
it's not top down there's one pack in
Colorado that six voters follow a
lawsuit then in Minnesota some random
three random guys follow a lawsuit and
they do it over and over again and and
here and and the crazy thing is there's
going to be different versions of the
same lawsuits filed in multiple States
and Trump as a single entity will
struggle to compete against all of that
yeah maximum law fair so what what's the
what's the answer for Trump then I mean
what he can't fight all these lawsuits
he has to just fight he has to fight all
the lawsuits and he has to do this and
uh they're going to lie they're going to
cheat and they're going to steal but
once again I tell you first and foremost
everybody needs to vote in a Title Wave
and convince everybody to go vote bring
your friends uh uh uh to vote tell them
every you know or whatever is legal in
your state you know if you're allowed to
ballot Harvest ballot Harvest you should
be knocking on doors and then uh the
real answer is going to be building
culture don't stuff The Ballot Box
illegally though but don't get caught
doing that it's legal in a lot of States
people need to understand that I'll tell
you about uh uh rollerblading is a
really great analogy on this one
rollerblading was the biggest action
sport in the world in the in the in the
early 90s had something like tens of
millions of participants yeah and they
did not Inspire young people to get
involved so 10 years AG gooes buy and
what happens you're still the best
you're a pro you're doing the bigger
tricks better than ever but there's no
one buying any products around what
you're doing no sponsorships and then
finally the X game says guys you're not
selling tickets anymore we're cutting
your event right you're gone you're
still the best in the in the world but
there's no one coming behind you
Republicans need to be inspiring young
people indoctrinating young people this
is the funny thing don't fall for the
left trp we absolutely want to
indoctrinate all of the young people
towards values of personal respons
ability meritocracy and Liberty and the
foundation of this country and all the
bad stuff can go away when the right
says oh it's bad the schools are
indoctrinating kids I'm like actually
that would be good if it was like for
American values but it's not it's weird
well garbage yeah I I I I get kind of
caught up on this this Republican
Democrat talk obviously I'm a
Libertarian but the the problem for me
is like all the worst like policy that's
ever passed in my lifetime has always
had bipartisan support but I'm not I'm
not trying to make it seem like
Republicans and Democrats I don't like
the Republican party or the Democratic
part party you've got a handful of
Republicans right now seven who are very
libertarian leaning and populist and so
that's why I'm saying American values if
you believe in the Constitution if you
believe in individual liberties rights
and meritocracy that's the
indoctrination we want SC the parties
I'm a I'm a Libertarian American first
populist candidate that's that's what
I've been telling everybody and some of
the Libertarians don't like that I say
that but that's just CU they don't
understand what any of those words mean
pretty much what does it mean well
populist is just you're speaking to the
the outside of the ruling Elite right
this regime that like that rules us
through the the Academia and and uh you
know the corporate news media and the
rich and the and the politicians we're
speaking to the middle class and lower
right like these people that are
everyday Americans that get up every
morning and put on their work boots and
go to work that's what a populist
message is speaking to those people not
the not the elite and American first
here's the thing like Libertarians are
like oh you know anti- borders and and
and oh you can't say America first but
it's like you're running to govern
Americans how could you not be an
American first and in fact if we're
going to be this anti- intervention
interventionist right like these
anti-war guys then you have to be
America first that's the one of the most
important principles of that is that we'
got to stop like meddling in these
foreign interventions yeah it shouldn't
be shameful to be America first if
you're an americ America First is a good
thing if you're running to be a
politician in America and as as a
Libertarian candidate I may be one of
the first guys that actually gets that
and that's you know that's just who I am
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net